actually it's the same book pretty much
power to persuade was the first edition
then we reissued a second edition which
probably had 10% new material and we
changed the title so it's uh they're
essentially a similar book it grew out
of my time kind of two things one was
teaching at the Kennedy School of
Government and I couldn't find the book
that I felt told students who were
thinking of careers in government but
also can I'll get to this in a second
but also in the private sector I
couldn't find the book I really liked
and I had a lot of experience myself
working in government what I wanted to
do was come up was produce a book that
would help people figure out what it is
they wanted to accomplish and figure out
how to accomplish it and the model I
came up with was a compass that
everybody had to think about their North
which was their bosses their South their
staff their East their colleagues and
their West which were those outside
their organization but they still had to
interact with how they had to work off
of those four directions of their
compass to help them figure out what it
was they could accomplish and to help
pave the way to - to accomplishing it
and that that was essentially the the
model or the structure and I interviewed
a lot of people and looked at a lot of
people and essentially said what what
explains why some intelligent people
succeed and others fail and I wrote it
mainly at the time for people going into
government but I have increasingly
concluded that it it makes just as much
sense for people who are running a
fortune 500 company because when you
look at what the world's these people
now run or operate in it looks an awful
lot like a political world they're
facing all these independent
constituencies they're under the glare
of 24/7 media and a constant news cycle
they've got to deal with unions they've
got a deal with competition globally and
and domestically they've got to deal
with environmental groups and citizen
groups and state legislatures on
Washington DC so if you're the head of
if I say any of the major financial
institutions so you're the head of an
automobile company but pretty much
anything else these days you are
operating in an unbelievably crowded
comp
located competitive space so the age if
it ever existed when a CEO could live in
some kind of splendid isolation and
issue commands and have those commands
followed faithfully those days simply
don't exist so again I look at the life
of a CEO or someone who wants to be a
CEO and I look at the life of someone
who's either a cabinet chief or an
assistant secretary and some cabinet
department in Washington and
increasingly the kinds of political
challenges they face to figure out what
their agenda is a more important to get
to translate an agenda into reality
their worlds look awfully similar to me
and that's that's what I tried to do is
come up with tools that would help
people navigate extraordinarily
challenging political environments which
increasingly you find yourselves in
to me loyalty has two dimensions one is
to speak truth to power so wherever you
are that one of the things you you owe
it to your conscience you owe it to your
career but you owe it to your boss is to
tell your boss not what he or she wants
to hear but what they need to hear and
you need to be creative but you also
just need to be intellectually honest
and if you disagree you need to disagree
in here is why the other half of loyalty
up though of what you owe your boss is
when your boss decides makes a decision
and it doesn't necessarily go your way
you've got to live with it you you can't
undermine it you can't be disloyal and
you don't want to resign every time you
don't have your way it's something I
actually write about in the Iraq book I
had to live with the question of whether
to stay or resign when when decisions
didn't go my way and my view is uh
either it has to be a very big decision
that doesn't go your way and those are
rare fortunately in life or it has to be
the accumulation of a large number of
medium-sized decisions that don't go
your way and you say hey this isn't the
right place for me but otherwise it
seems to me you essentially part of what
you owe your boss loyalty up is a
willingness to work with them if you've
been hurt out and even if it goes
against you that of you you don't
essentially pick up your marbles and go
home go home I mentioned this because in
my experience most people often do
neither a lot of people are afraid to
speak truth to power because they're
feared there's going to be retribution
of retaliation and secondly if they
don't get the decision they want one way
or another they sabotage it they're not
enthusiastic or they don't do all that
they could insured they're not
professional about implementing it I
also say while we're on it there's also
loyalty down from north to south what
bosses owe their subordinates and you it
seems to me you owe them their day in
court a chance to make the arguments if
you go against them you you've got it I
think you owe it to them an explanation
as to why and if you do those things I
think you're more likely to get the sort
of behavior you want from your from your
from your staff
you